okay here we go
warzone Kings one-minute time control 45
players have entered 1890 average rating
here we go alright double those points
let's go eform let us start can I get
that Queen if she recaptures and now I'm
getting a pond though definitely getting
a pond and maybe a fork f7 it's a fork I
have the rook and I have the bishop
kitchen sink maintain a few here no
matter what no they resigned back to
tournament whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa well
how did that happen there's a lot of
people with victories already three
three couple twos we're only uh that was
like a fifty second game last time this
got into uh this got into a stone wall
I'm going to avoid that I kicked that
night out of there if he goes there
actually let's do it now why don't we
zone my bishop around maybe get this
here on push well now let's do it that's
a little too nervous there no no no no
no no no no let me go with I got rid of
the light square bishop should I be
afraid of that no I'm gonna get the
light square Bishop out there off the
board oh there might just be a pawn push
and I hear something there might be what
do I do I think I might just take kick
that Queen away
alright let's just stop that whoa whoa
whoa whoa the queen is dead she's
trapped running out of room is that
clean Knight g8 right no good solution
here okay Queen takes rook I guess it's
the best but I sneak my king out less
than 10 now moving okay let's get back
here then this okay I'm on the bishop
and down on time back to chairman oh man
31 don't tell me it's happening again 31
points and six games in okay let's go to
gambit
Wow six games oh man
engage engage fishing go fish fishing
it's happening again
again it's happening
haha bishop block if there's a queen
check otherwise just clean h8 unless
they're sneaky with like Queen to h4 or
something let's just block here and on
the Queen and a mate threat really gonna
take that Bishop now it's mate no matter
what no matter what back to tournament
1245 points don't tell me there's more
corruption and more cheating going on
you get 45 points oh man
seven games in seven out of seven that
guy's gone mad mule train has gone mad
seven out of seven ah let's see
Oh somebody got a quick resign and it
was me that time 53:20 and town squared
here we go efore here we go I started
off strong without an e4 and then I
don't know what to do after that before
and then just get the other pieces out
my bishops gonna Oh mouse slipper they
heard they definitely heard totally
relate to those mouse lips yes they are
definitely definitely painful if my
knight is hit I go here with check
there's a fork light square bishop let's
just back up I have Queen h5 no I don't
hang on there hang on
not so fast I have Queen g6
Queen g6 let's back up Queen here push
that night around maybe get Mather my
other pawn involved here pawn push
coming up oh I have bishop check on c5
no no no no no no whoa this is me I have
made its main achievement seventy one
thirty five thirty the assassin is up
there
ten games for the top dog and then five
or six for a second place guy all right
yeah second place guy okay let's get
this in I kill that Bishop maybe you
strict that Bishop maybe not here you
know you want to do that
okay the bishop has to run away it's
gonna get up the light-square bishop I
want to get this move in here we go I
have the light-square bishop now you
take that night let's come here first
should I have just taken that okay now
they took and no what do you want to do
with the light square is okay I'm okay
with uhm yeah he's not even trying to
take that bishop why am I in prima mode
that's the that's the lamest free move
right there
oh not here let's come here it's safe I
want to back my light square Bishop out
and get on that light square diagonal
let's come here first
okay obvious color bishops oh you had to
do that move didn't you get out of there
get out huh here we go here we go it's a
little scary though hang on let's get
rid of this rook what a pain
what a giant pain opposite colored
bishops uh come over here King I'm gonna
lose one of these pawns no I'm not
let's get this guy there and then King
position King position oh what a stupid
move I only have nine seconds King here
that's what you meant
okay your pawns going ah let's back up
target that pond um okay could this work
out please
King right here okay this is working out
here right here right here there down on
time back to tournament 71 Oh slipped up
71 49 42 14 I might get paired up ace
rook efore all right we've been here
before dropping upon is that okay though
not taking it Bishop d6 I'll take it
this time oh I guess he's dead he's a
dead one he's a dead man let's go here
and then here no I'm glad that oh that
was a bad Mouse lip oh this is scary
let's do this
I got a runaway I'm defending h2 can I
get this up here I open this up here
it's just scary this is very scary here
I should have done this beep on move a
lot sooner a lot sooner
uh-oh okay maybe I could get this in get
that Bishop out of there you need to go
Bishop take the pawn get the a file open
up okay oh let's give a check I had that
earlier didn't I we got a file there's
got to be made there's probably made
this probably made is this gonna be okay
it's gonna be okay it's very tense right
here very tense situation it's give a
check who has to be taken another check
oh there's got to be mate now that's me
that's me that's me back to turn in 56
got scary 111 how do you catch 111 Wow
20 minutes remaining there's a how many
game
Oh quick resigner
13 he has 13 games and 131 64 this is
the guy I need to beat him I need to
beat him if I have any chance big game
big game right here
Oh even if I win even if I win things
still aren't looking too great right
right
they're just now looking too great no
matter what oh I almost forgot that my
queen is hanging oh man you can't be
forgetting that your queen is hanging
man what is that move even do oh okay no
there's some reason reasoning behind it
okay let's shut down that Bishop I want
to get this pawn the bishop has to go
back to f8 they didn't go back to f8 f6
needs to be played the bishop is playing
in this direction now come on over here
Knight
where does my knight wanna be oh what a
stupid spot my knight wants me on f3 oh
here comes the night big bad night on f5
big bad night oh that's a good that
would have been a good move just throw
the knight right in there I just dropped
upon no I didn't ah
tricky stuff watch out for tricks watch
out for those tricks oh oh that's a
scary spot to go to to go to you know
what I meant you know what I meant I was
fumbling with the words again get that
night out of there before it's too late
oh what a giant pawn center I could take
that pawn twice they missed it
oh hang on hang on
is it gonna be okay I'm on the bishop
give me that pond what's the clock
situation they have that and I just take
this Bishop could I win that let me just
get this guy going police say it's gonna
be okay
it might not be okay
Oh No let's come here I think it's safe
don't throw your up to the corner
whatever you do now you could actually
it's okay to do that now
oh they took that around this it's
getting rid of it
just can't be easy let me get this guy
ah get out of there
give me this take that oh why am I not
moving
Clark situation anything keep this pond
around don't move the pond don't move
the pond come on gimme gimme gimme gimme
gimme
129 103 that's what I needed 17 minutes
remaining I chipped away a little bit at
the leader oh man
that's all I needed was a silly little
pond in my opponents clock to be it
goose egg that was the plan I should
have played b5 ha ha ha a nail-biter
that was a nail-biter
ok you're dead if you go to b3 he didn't
go to b3 ok
get out of there night I got this pawn
give me that pond let's come back d3 is
gonna be played get this night out get
that night out hang on let's keep this
Knight dead get the half-open a file if
there's capture here we go
pawn push this pawn push there now let's
get this buy this is this buy this guy
okay here we go forks forks forks on b3
everybody loves a fork okay let's take
this now Bishop b4 is deadly deadly with
insurance right there insurance the pond
I picked up okay let's just trade a
bunch trade a bunch take that pawn it
throw it in a pin get rid of the knight
avoid the tricky Knight center all costs
right here
checkmate threat control g2 g2 g2 g2
flight square
let's come up here bond push or
something I should just treat drugs what
are you doing tray drugs one pair at
least they're down on time gonna take
that I want to play up here and secure
my Knights position like you can't be
kicked away I'd pressure on this they're
gonna resign they're not resigning
where's the mate me happening soon 1 and
then 2 back to tournament 149 uh-uh 149
123 15 minutes remaining
we're only halfway there 149 that's a
lot of points a lot of points right
there ok let's do this stop b5 with the
tempo one day it's gonna happen one day
from now it's just it's gonna happen I'm
gonna buy it I'm gonna get a new Mouse
I'm gonna find one that's gonna be a
good friend to me and not ever have a
bad click again this okay well if you
take care I have tricks over here all
right house I would fork I also had a
fork around here police say that works
it doesn't really work no I have this I
get that guy on the rug
oh I just drop my queen oh you didn't
see that I promise you you didn't see
that ah man what am I talking about now
I'm in check
oh no my rooks getting hit bad news
around every corner you can't come back
from this there's no way piece is
falling you can't come back from this
why are you playing on take that pond
you know you want to take them take them
you still want to take them come on
waiting on hang on sneakiness sneakiness
sneakiness oh hang on defend defend
defend they have 13 seconds you can't
win with just 13 seconds there's a pin
get that King over here come on come on
come on come on come on
come on come on come on come on don't
place me in a pin let's run a check-in
oh that King is so good that King is so
good
wait a second oh I just dropped my rook
I'm in check
oh I'm still in checking oh I'm down on
top oh you can't win if you drop your
Queen like that that's not the first
time I um ah earlier against mule train
I said I almost dropped my queen no no
no pieces can't move Queens are dropping
oh I'm playing on tilt
I can't even throw a fishing pole in
here this is the anti fish fishing pole
formation bad news and every variation
man I want to cry did it take my queen
man note to self if you're gonna go for
the Grand Prix attack and weasel your
little queen around - hang on let's just
take that if you're gonna weasel it
around to that what Square h4 as soon as
that night on e7 moves you need to do
something about your queen okay
oh the Queen has to run to the corner
she can't be too happy I can't she ah
she's scared in the corner look at the
Queen in the corner she's silly silly
clean alert does that even mean what
does that even mean stop it with those
lines
ridiculous absolutely ridiculous they're
in a giant pen Oh pins everywhere
ouch that's a tough one to stomach right
there that is ouch town right there 121
89 forget about 120 let's just look at
the leaders I should just I should just
quit play and sit back watch other
people not drop their queen
man okay here this is what I'm talking
about this is exactly what I'm talking
about now watch watch oh I won't want to
go there now cuz the bishops here maybe
I will
we'll see what happens don't chop the
Queen whatever you do that's what I'm
getting at oh you could do it you could
do it you could do it just defend the
night if he's attacked preserve your
bishop I really want to go to a four but
another case of mouse live problems okay
Queens coming out to h4 don't die on
this square this time bond push or this
may be clean here is looking pretty
decent this pawn is pinned oh oh I could
take twice they might drop their queen I
know the people I know that feeling
that's me that's me back to chairman 140
do I really have any hope the inflection
of my voice just said I had hope right
there that back to tournament phrase
okay there's actually um I can maybe get
second
can I get second I just want to play d4
let's shut that Bishop down there's a
bunch of people with um low one for like
140 s in the 140s I supposed to do that
a little bit later after castles get
that away okay now there might be
something is there gonna be something
just take that night and there's
definitely something i phone is well
aware of that uh nonsense well aware of
it take him take him he is a free piece
I need to defend here I can't rely upon
my knight anymore
or can I let's do this now let's do this
it's very scary over here whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa
what's going on here Bishop back to d6
mean to threaten
oh there are now this square it wouldn't
about me Oh mate the king is gonna
weasel way over here
keep checks right here right here
where's the mate over the night the king
is going for a hike he is flying what
does that even doing ah it's not
accomplishing much that was a stupid
move gotta watch out for this in the
meantime let's stop rook here I have
this covered my rook involved rook right
here on d4 forks on the Queen okay I
know what I'm doing from here pretty
sure I know what I'm doing at this point
ten seconds ten seconds get a queen and
then mate happening soon what are you
I'm a queen king over there
I can't move your queen like that this
is mate next just go anything anything
don't let your clock tick okay back to
terminal 161 81 there's still 8 minutes
remaining
219 181 176 I'm not even can in confetti
zone Brent again Brent again is this the
guy that beat me no I don't think so
maybe I'm forgetting that guy was our
girl ok let's go over to g3 ok they're
gonna take that pond they wouldn't do
that would they take on C to push pawn
push here yeah maybe I should have done
that a move sooner let's develop there's
night here
I really don't want to give up man there
goes my dark star bishop but i've
pressure on f7 a little bishop here
well sing on your queen uh let's also
hang on your ruff they would have my
bishop there okay get your knight right
here let's keep your rook here to stop
Queen here I want to get that bishop
what a tough guy he is
Wow is he tough let's go my knight I
know five might be tougher on g7 let's
take here making two threat me an H mean
to H take that rope just Queen
disappointed f8 is looking good very
nice Queens come off and now I need to
get here grab this pond and defend B
just in time rook here I can defend my
epon actually let's stop it there might
have been some hot pin going on there's
gonna be that move or not
my king can bump up now clock situation
and I have a lot of time the rook is
gonna get active now not much I can do
about it
not much I could do defend this pawn
might be defendable I just dropped that
so we're gonna sneak back it might be
trapped whoa
sneaky traps it's trapped the King
hunted him right down have enough time
to convert it do I have enough time I
grabbed that pun bump over its come
right here and then here and then get on
light squares that's gonna be the plan
get my knight here my knight here my
king here and grab that pawn on c5 with
check clock situation there down on time
back to tournament 180 - 49 - OH - 180 -
there's five minutes and change
remaining ah man H pawn attack that's my
only hope
get out of there Bishop the each file is
not opened up but I mean - threat no
shutdown
Allen was officially shut down oh there
goes a light script [ __ ] or a dark
square bishop night for let's get out of
that I want to get him b5 b5 and what
next they're not moving get here push
here in the center maybe that's a good
response get development in oh they
grabbed that pawn push all right let's
open it up that rook is unprotected
maybe there's some sneaky stuff oh I'm
on the Queen they might resign are they
gonna resign we're tight or tied at time
just resign come on
oh they're not resigning take my knight
keep this night out of here they're in a
fork that I have to do that the rook is
still hit looking for mates where are
those maids get rid of that night Oh
kitchen sink they're throwing everything
at me ah their kitchen sinking me here
the upper kitchen sink get a new kitchen
sink right here they're letting their
time tick
ah what a time ticker less than 10 less
than 10 there milk in every last second
every last second back to tournament I'm
in fifth no I'm not I'm in third oh I'm
just trying to hold on to third and x
squared
um here we go
here we go
oh try no he got into third place first
and second are way off our way off even
if I had 20 more with if I would have
won that game that I lost why should I
get points for this I doubled the points
this is a he musta logged off because he
he almost always just ends up playing
this Anton saw him I think he has a
connection issue in the meantime I'm
drifting back and forth come on give me
the W with this game come on look at the
standings oh this is brutal
I want that confetti even if it's the
third no I'm in fifth oh no no no no no
no no I can get this one give me some
points for this it's not gonna be very
many points it's not gonna be very many
and I have time for one more there's 235
remaining give me the points what's
happening they have to check the server
Oh another 10 seconds just got to make
sure I have to make sure in the meantime
that clock is still ticking for the
tournament back to tournament there was
a technical error I didn't even get any
points
ah man game aborted due to technical
error
oh no you can't rebound from a technical
error oh man ah I didn't get any points
there's no hope now I waited a minute
right there and I got no points for it
ah you can forget about it if you're
here waiting for the confetti don't even
waste your time don't even waste your
time age to age - hang on hang on
- twenty - twenty come on you could take
third come on come on come on come on
come on
oh I gotta go really really quick I have
to win with um what like I have to win
with like I can't spend any time here no
time at all I just I can't spend any
time at all oh I should just take in or
something take that night play here
where's the maid threat I should have
played Queenie formate threaten one g6 I
play h5 54 seconds remaining how they
gonna take that one have been mate right
away I just want to take on h6 there's a
queen check on e5 oh come on so close
it's Castle take here next no matter
what make it once right bishop check its
mate what does it mean what does it mean
unpacked a tournament - four come on
tick tick tick tick tick please please
give me that third place come on come on
come on come on is this guy gonna resign
he's at negative 59 see a quick resigner
give me that night is he quick resigner
he's not a quick resigner there's a fork
if I go there don't go there come on 10
seconds please give me that third place
come on come on come on come on I just
stopped tonight
oh just finish college college college
before someone else wins what I got
third plates confetti I'll take the
third-place confetti Oh a technical air
and everything oh man gimme that
confetti I'll take it let me close out
oh man do I get excited over paper paper
it's not even paid for virtual paper
know what I'm saying good games oh wow
a buzzer-beater sort of at the end there
to sneak in that win 2 for 289 mule
train Wow
23 games in 20 games in four second
twenty two forty two thirty four to
twenty two to twenty Wow a lot of um I
could have been one two three four five
six of us were kind of up there very
very close
oh okay very good let me close out